Agent Kister was running for his life. Every
breath had burned in his throat, like inhaling
chlorine gas. He sped through the dark, surrounded
by deafening metallic screams that bounced off the
eternity of pipes scaling and strangling the
walls around him. As far as he was concerned,
this was what Hell looked like. A nightmare
boiler room that would somehow be less scary
if Freddy Kreuger was there, because at least
there’d be some kind of recognizably human
intelligence to reason with. The Pipes
- SCP-015 - are truly unknowable.
As an SCP Foundation Mobile Task Force
member, Agent Kister had seen some truly
horrific things in the line of duty. He’d been
there during SCP-682 containment breaches,
firing an assault rifle at the beast as its
scales hardened into a bulletproof carapace.
He’d seen the femur breaker used on some poor,
godforsaken D-Class to lure Uncle Larry back into
the containment chamber for some midnight fun.
In the most anxiety-inducing mission of his life,
he’d once even bagged 096’s weeping face
after it slaughtered a whole mountain village.
And these damn pipes were going
to be the thing that killed him.
He turned a sharp corner, trying to
block out the screams of his teammates.
Four of them had been sent in - The rest were
already dead, or worse. Stupid, stupid, stupid.
They’d made a classic military mistake:
Underestimating the capabilities of their
enemy. And in Agent Kister’s experience,
this had always been a capital offense.
All to install that machine. That stupid
little remote control reconnaissance
vehicle. That’s what they’d given their lives for…
Agent Kister tried to blink away the
memory of Agent Montgomery’s face.
Monty was the youngest member of the team -
28 years old, his first major mission into
the heart of a skip. Kister wanted to
remember him how he’d first seen him:
A bright-eyed greenhorn, ready to protect the
human race from the horrors that lay in the dark.
But he’d been the first to go
when everything got F.U.B.A.R.
It was the smaller pipes that got Monty. Four
of them shot out, spearing his lungs and heart,
pinning him in place. Even if they tried to cut
him out, he would have been a goner. He coughed
up blood and went ghost-white faster than you’d
ever imagine. Kister would never forget, for what
little time he had left to live, the horrible
sight of the light leaving that kid’s eyes.
And all this because one of them had
tripped on one of the pipes on the way out
and busted it. The mission was already
done. What an awful, pointless way to die.
Kister was yanked from his aching
thoughts by a sudden obstacle in the way.
A huge, towering pipe that looked like
a pillar of flesh, covered in bulbous,
staring eyes. The thought crossed his mind, Jesus,
these pipes can really be made out of anything…
He looked down and saw a series of rubber pipes
slithering towards his feet along the ground like
snakes. It was time to run again, but how long
could you even run for when the very location
around you wants you dead? They should’ve
sent the Mole Rats ]for a job like this.
The infinitely reconfiguring pipes changed
the layout of the warehouse around him,
making escape seem all the more unfeasible.
That’s when he started thinking about the
terrible thing that’d happened to Agent Greene…
When 015 turned hostile, they needed to make a run
for it, fast. It wasn’t unlike being a pathogen
inside a living body - You start to make trouble,
and the body’s immune system is going to come
for you. And one of the most common mechanisms
for a body fighting a virus is a fever - A sudden
increase in temperature that burns out the threat.
The group turned and ran as the
pipes started twisting towards them.
Agent Greene panicked and began striking
at the pipes around him with his hands.
The first instinct would have been to shoot,
but no guns were permitted inside the SCP-015
warehouse. It reacted severely to any kind
of tool being brought into its proximity.
Several dead agents and researchers could tell
you all about this if they hadn’t made that
same mistake. But when things were already
going sideways, it left them defenseless.
Agent Greene was soon boxed in, caged by
a latticework of pipes in varying sizes.
He tried desperately to push them out of the way
and make an escape route, but the hissing noise
was getting louder and louder as the pipes
started to turn a glowing red around him.
After all, when a body needs to deal with a
hostile foreign object, it burns out the threat.
Kister wished he could shake the awful,
high-pitched wail that Agent Greene made when
the heat inside his pipe cage became unbearable.
It was like seeing a human get caught inside a
giant bug zapper. His skin went black and charred,
and soon after, the heat had risen to such an
insane degree that Agent Greene was reduced
to little more than ash in his pipe furnace.
But Kister couldn’t afford to dwell. He kept
running, vaulting over a long, ragged pipe
made from stinking human hair. This terrible
place stank of motor oil, mold, and death,
But maybe those perceptions had been colored
by the terrible things he’d seen here.
There it was again. That awful choked
screaming coming from inside the pipes.
Agent Boggs. It was a nightmare to hear him shriek
like that. Boggs had been one of the toughest men
that Kister had ever met - He mentored him,
back when he first became an MTF Member.
Having Boggs on the team meant experience.
It meant safety. It meant that things would
go okay. Kister had seen Boggs stare down some
of the most horrifying skips imaginable and not
even flinch. And yet, here he was, screaming
and bawling like a hurt child in the pipes.
Boggs was the next one to get taken.
As he and Kister ran through the dark,
trying to find a way out, they’d passed a
huge pipe made of a soft, foam-like substance.
A seam in the side of the pipe had yawned
open, and a tangle of writhing tentacles,
each one barbed with thorns like the stem of a
rosebush. They enveloped Agent Boggs, cutting
into his weathered skin. He gasped in pain, unable
to scream. It happened so fast. Before Kister even
had a chance to grab him, he was pulled into
the pipe and the crevice sealed behind him.
And that was when the screaming
really started for poor Agent Boggs.
Kister hoped, for his sake,
that he would die sometime soon.
Shrouded in the fog of his dark thoughts,
Agent Kister turned a corner and felt cold,
hard metal suddenly collide with
his face, breaking his nose with an
unpleasant crunch. He’d been clotheslined
by a low pipe that hadn’t been there before,
and now, he was laid out on his back, face
humming with pain. Thoughts and feelings swam.
He looked up into the seemingly infinite web
of pipes weaving through the air above him. He
was right earlier, he just knew it. The place
was Hell. It’d be his eternal resting place.
Suddenly, a new, huge shape moved into
the space above him. A pipe of ancient,
rusty iron that looked older than even
the warehouse holding this whole mess.
Right above him, there was a huge valve fixed
into the pipe’s belly. He watched, helpless, as
the valve opened itself with a squeal, and a huge,
dark mass came pouring out of it onto his body.
A sudden weight. A sudden warmth. Sound and
movement and tiny scratching claws. Rats.
Thousands of big, hungry, black rats with
gnarled yellow teeth, clumps of fur purged
from their skin by mange. Big, ropey, worm-like
tails swaying and whipping at the air. Who knows
how long they’d been in that pipe? Who knows
when these rats had eaten anything that wasn’t
their brothers and sisters? And here was Agent
Kister, given unto them by the glorious pipes.
The last thing he ever saw were those nasty
yellow teeth, because they ate his eyes first.
Word of the four disappeared - and presumed
dead - operatives soon reached Dr. Charles
Ogden Gears, the legendarily taciturn senior
researcher that managed the SCP-015 project,
among a myriad of others.
His face didn’t betray a flicker of emotion when
he was informed about the men lost to SCP-015.
It wasn’t that he didn’t feel for them,
more that he deemed it both unproductive
and unprofessional to dwell on the deaths
of personnel when carrying out their duties.
After all, being killed by an anomaly
was simply an occupational hazard,
and a generous stipend would be sent to their
families to compensate for their tragic loss.
Dr. Gears simply asked, “Was the mission
successful, in spite of the casualties?
Did the team manage to install the
Modular Robotic Vehicle at the epicenter?”
He was told that the MRV had been
successfully installed, at least.
Dr. Gears nodded and began scheduling
a second exploratory mission for a few
months in the future to check
the status of the machine.
Still, in the meantime, the MRV would chug
along, doing what humans couldn’t - or perhaps,
shouldn’t - do within the nightmarish mess
of ever-growing pipes. It would roll through,
collecting information on everything around it,
hopefully giving the SCP Foundation an inroad
to mapping the whole thing without needing to
send a cavalcade of staff into the danger zone
just to discover more about these peculiar pipes.
Sure, some lives were lost getting it in there,
but this measure would likely save
even more lives in the long run.
That was… Until something went wrong.
The exact nature of what had happened
to the MRV inside the domain of the pipes was a
mystery, but it wasn’t doing its intended job,
and the SCP Foundation needed to find out why.
The second exploratory mission was required
much sooner than they’d initially anticipated,
with a dual purpose: Collecting the readings,
and finding out what exactly had
happened to the MRV in the first place.
He included a more specific set of instructions
for the next mission: Only three members of
personnel to enter SCP-015 this time, to minimize
potential loss. One trained technician to collect
and read the diagnostics, and two guards to
maintain discipline and safety under pressure.
With a setup like that, what
could possibly go wrong?
Dr. Gears’ various assistants began
headhunting the perfect team for the job.
Junior Researcher Lon, wanting to prove
herself and climb up the ranks, put her name
forward. She was young, intelligent, and
had the initiative to get the job done.
Though there was one thing that she hadn’t
disclosed when she was applying for this important
new position: Junior Researcher Lon suffered
from claustrophobia, the fear of enclosed spaces.
Then the hunt was on for the two members of
Foundation military personnel who’d escort
Lon to the MRV to take the readings.
Like the two priests in The Exorcist,
they decided to recruit one grizzled,
experienced operative and one extremely
cautious young buck straight out of
the Foundation MTF Training Academy.
The younger of the two operatives, codenamed Agent
Two, was careful and conscientious to a fault.
He did things by the book or not at all.
The older operative, codenamed Agent Six,
was quite the opposite. He’d done this job
long enough to operate solely on instinct,
and resented his employers for expecting
him to approach his missions any other way.
Lon, Agent Two, and Agent Six. The team
was assembled, and when the time came,
they were taken to SCP-015 to execute their
mission. It should have been simple enough:
Get in, collect the readings, and get back out.
Though a few weeks earlier, the same thing would
have been said for the mission to install
the MRV which left for Mobile Task Force
operatives dead or worse. Nothing was ever as
simple as it seemed when it came to SCP-015.
They were only allowed flashlights inside.
Anything else carried a substantial risk
of activating SCP-015’s defensive state,
putting all of their lives in jeopardy.
Lon had tried to keep things light, masking her
own terrible fear at this strange new situation.
She’d joked that perhaps the three
of them should get Mario hats,
seeing as they were plumbers now.
Agent Two had happily laughed along,
suggesting that perhaps he should be
Luigi. Agent Six was utterly unamused
by this whole situation and wanted no part of
it, which is honestly just so Wario of him.
They followed along a carefully-mapped route
through the pipes, being careful not to touch
any of them. After all, you never know what could
set SCP-015 off. Agent Six didn’t share in their
merriment or their concern. In fact, he had
contempt for them and this whole situation.
He thought Lon and Agent Two were a pair of
frightened, skittish children willing to buy
whatever Foundation-assigned bullhonkey they
were given. He didn’t believe that SCP-015 was
anywhere near as dangerous as they’d been told.
In all likelihood, knowing the eggheads up top,
they just didn’t want men of action like him
breaking any of their precious little toys
while conducting missions on their behalf.
This whole thing was a big, stupid joke.
As they ducked and weaved through the confines
of SCP-015, the tension between them all just
silently grew. Their flashlights played along the
pipes, revealing the insane variety of shapes,
sizes, compositions, and materials
in here. Wood, steel, flesh, bone,
glass, pressed ash, granite, and so
much more. And yet, there were no
pipes comprised of any standard pipe-making
material, like lead, PVC plastic, or copper.
It was undeniably freaky, but when
you work with SCPs for long enough,
you learn to stop asking questions about the more
minor forms of strangeness inherent to anomalies.
The composition only got narrower as
they delved deeper into the warehouse.
Lon felt the anxiety like a hand
gripping her throat and squeezing,
but tried still to keep it hidden.
Agent Six, the largest among them,
almost got stuck a few times, trying to crawl
into spaces too tight for him to fit. He felt
like murdering Lon when she threw out a casual
comparison to Winnie the Pooh in the process.
When they reached the MRV, it gave them an ounce
of momentary relief. The journey was halfway done.
But that comfort was quickly squashed by
seeing what had actually happened to the MRV:
It had been speared by a pipe, and new
pipes had grown through and out of it,
effectively rooting it in place. This caused
immediate debate among the group around one key
issue: Did this mean that the MRV was
now technically part of the pipes? And,
by extension, would the pipes feel the need
to defend themselves if the databanks were
removed from the MRV in order to deliver the
readings back to the researchers at Site-17?
While Lon and Agent Two carefully discussed the
issue, Agent Six lost his temper, and decided
to show these two foolish kids how it was done.
He claimed that the two of them were worrying
about a bunch of Foundation hooey that they were
inexperienced and gullible enough to believe:
As if this bunch of weird
pipes was actually dangerous!
It was like how every six anomalies there’s
apparently one capable of ending the world.
It’s all a bunch of overblown
fearmongering nonsense!
And to prove that he wasn’t just all talk
on this front, Agent Six pried open the top
of the MRV and slid out the data cards - which
seemed to be covered in some kind of viscous,
unpleasant liquid from the pipes that’d penetrated
the device. Still, he’d gotten what they came for.
He could have done this whole thing
alone, without this pair of bedwetters.
He scoffed and said, “Kids. I
don’t know how you two survive.”
But he shouldn’t have spoken so soon. The
large pipe that he didn’t even realize he
was standing on opened up beneath his feet,
and seconds later, he was immersed up to his
shoulders in it. Six began to let out the
most horrifying shrieks you’ve ever heard,
and when Agent Two and Lon ran over to
try to help him out, they realized why.
The pipe below Agent Six was
filled with flowing molten iron.
By the time they pulled Agent Six out - Well,
Agent Six from the shoulders up, considering
that was all that was left - he was already dead.
And despite the actual aggressor being destroyed,
SCP-015 wasn’t done. It was ready to clean
house. As Agent Two and Lon attempted to flee,
some eye-level pipes around them burst,
firing crystalized glass into their faces,
cutting into their skin and
eyes. But they needed to push on
despite the pain if they
wanted to survive and get out.
The two of them ran, horrifying noises of
twisting and bursting pipes roaring behind them.
Pipes made of thorns and bones started to grow,
blocking off their exits until they were trapped.
Lon, utilizing her small frame, was able
to crawl through a gap in the pipes into an
adjoining chamber. Two was given a horrifying
surprise when a pipe burst near his hand,
showering his flesh in thick, corrosive
gunk. His hand melted away at the wrist.
As Lon called for help in the tiny,
cramped chamber she was locked in,
Two ran off to try and find an exit, where
he could bring more people in to help them.
But it would already be too late for poor
Lon. A thick, honey-like substance began
bleeding into the chamber, disgusting in its
overpowering saccharine flavor and gloopy,
viscous thickness. The chamber seemed to
get smaller and smaller as Lon screamed
and the honey level rose. Eventually, it got
higher than her mouth and nose could reach.
She gave a horrifying final gurgle, and then she
was gone, entombed forever between the pipes.
Agent Two kept running. His flashlight
was beginning to die, but he didn’t care.
As his eyes bled from the splinters of glass
and what was left of his hand dripped from the
jagged nub of his wrist, all he could do was
keep moving forwards. He panted and screamed
and stumbled in the dark until he tripped on
something he didn’t notice and pitched forwards.
He tumbled into the gaping maw of a nearby
pipe, surrounded by unseeable, unknowable ooze,
as he tumbled further down into the seemingly
infinite darkness. It was too dark to see and
too cramped to move anywhere but straight down.
All he could do was scream and scream and scream
until his voice was hoarse and his throat bled,
though nobody was there to even hear his cries.
Days later, when his skin started
to shred off, it was almost welcome.
Dr. Gears would later receive the
news of this tragically failed
mission and the three operatives
now declared MIA because of it.
He sighed, and wrote up his report on
the matter, closing with the sentence:
“Data deemed non-vital in light of lost staff.
SCP-015 classification level review suggested.”
Now go check out “SCP-049 - Boiled,
Scrambled and Fried - Plague Doctor
Tale” and “What Actually Happened
to Major Alexei Belitrov?
SCP-2273 - Tale” for more chilling tales
from the files of the SCP Foundation!